[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat pour cette émission
spéciale de parlement hebdo largement
consacré à la campagne des
présidentielles qui bat son plein
bonjour michael boder katia bonjour à
tous est notre invité yves marie cann
vous êtes le directeur des études
politiques à l'institut et là on va nous
parler des sondages et on commence tout
de suite il m'a rien que vous publiez
donc votre tout dernier sondage on va
regarder le premier panneau ensemble qui
vous voulez bien aux analyse la
situation
emmanuel macron toujours en timing
mairie avec 23 5% devant marine le pen à
un point derrière françois fillon
troisième à 20% et ensuite arrive jean
luc mélenchon 18 5 % et loin derrière
benoît hamon ils se marient kane avec si
peu d'écart entre le lait le carré de
tête si je puis dire
on est dans la marge d'erreur ça veut
dire que tout est possible et que les
indécis vont faire la différence
oui probablement c'est vrai qu'on voit
que le depuis maintenant une dizaine de
jours voire même une quinzaine de jours
l'écart se resserre entre les quatre
premiers on voit très bien
très clairement les courbes convergé ce
qui est un facteur d'incertitude parce
qu'on est dans la marge d'erreur ça veut
dire que lorsqu'on a quatre candidats
qui sont à des niveaux aussi proches les
uns des autres ça veut dire qu'en gros
on a aujourd'hui au moins en théorie si
configuration de second tour possible
donc ça c'est tout à fait inédit par
rapport aux deux précédentes élections
et vivre est inédit par rapport aux 2 et
de précédentes élections présidentielles
à savoir qu'en 2007 et en 2012
il y avait une incertitude dans roue
cette incertitude c'était de savoir
qu'est ce qu'ils allaient ressortir
premier finalement des votes entre
ségolène royal et sarkozy ou entre
hollande et sarkozy
là où est dans le même parce que dans le
même temps il y avait un écart de 8 à 10
points entre les deux premiers et leurs
poursuivants donc l'assemblée à l'asse
astier là c'est plus la même question
on a un écart nous dans notre sondage en
sondage de cinq points seulement entre
le premier emmanuel macron et jean luc
mélenchon qui est en quatrième position
et quand on tient compte des dynamiques
en plus on peut se dire que le
rapprochement des cours peut encore se
poursuivre dans les jaunes poursuivre
dans les jours qui viennent
tendez évidemment les candidats haïtiens
présidentielle qui nous disent je ne
crois pas aux sondages et ça c'est une
effectivement c'est une photo à
l'instant t d'une étude d'opinion est ce
que vous craignez vous le soir du 23
avril qu on vous regarde avec des gros
yeux c'est possible à condition toujours
quand même d'avoir à l'esprit que les
sondages ils n'ont pas vocation à
prédire le résultat de l'élection par
définition à son avis me rappelait
également il faut le rappeler parce
qu'un sondage qui réalisait à dix jours
du premier tour il n'est pas prédictifs
du résultat final
il y aura par définition des écarts par
rapport à ce que l'on mesure aujourd'hui
est ce que l'on verra dans les urnes le
23 avril il y aura très certainement
aussi des écarts entre ce qui sera
mesuré à 48 heures du scrutin et ce qui
sortira des urnes là aussi au premier
tour en revanche effectivement l'intérêt
des sondages c'est l'instant la photo
qui permettent d'obtenir un instant t
mais surtout la dynamique de campagne
qu'il permet d'objectiver c'est à dire
que l'on voit effectivement quels sont
les liens voilà les candidats qui
élimine les campagnes du rapport
favorable n'est des vents favorables et
se rencontrent au contraire qui font
face à des difficultés importe dynamique
de campagne on va le rappeler et vous
êtes avec quelques instituts mais là on
voit très nettement que la dynamique de
campagne est en baisse notamment pour
deux pour emmanuel macron d'une part sa
baisse un peu mais surtout surtout
marine le pen pour vous oui
effectivement c'est une c'est quelque
chose que l'on observe maintenant depuis
deux mois marine le pen à son plus haut
elle avait atteint jusqu'à 28% des
intentions de vote à la fin à la fin
février
elle est aujourd'hui attendre à 22-22 et
demi ça veut dire qu'elle a quand même
perdu 5 à 6 points en termes
d'intentions de vote tout au long de la
campagne et c'est la plus forte baisse
observée après celle de benoît hamon
donc c'est dire que marine le pen même
si elles gardent elles restent à un
niveau qui permet lui permet de
prétendre à la qualification pour le
second tour
sermon d'un homme qui a pas de dynamique
de campagne autour de la candidature de
marine le pen justement selon votre
sondage pour le deuxième tour où vous
vous donnez à une estimation 35%
d'intentions de vote pour marine le pen
65% pour emmanuel macron ça c'est
l'effet direct de l'illustration du
plafond de verre oui effectivement on le
voit bien à travers ce résultat alors
qu'ils résident entendu une intention de
vote c'est à dire que l'une le subsea
rapport de force il peut évoluer dans
l'hypothèse où marine le pen
emmanuel macron seraient les deux
qualifiés pour le second tour mais ça
montre aussi combien il va être sans
doute être dit
s'il de marine le pen d'enfoncer le
fameux plafond de verre si elle est
qualifiée pour le second tour parce que
même si elle est plus forte qu'elle ne
l'était en 2012
elle n'est pas suffisamment forte pour
prétendre à la victoire à l'élection
présidentielle sauf à compter finalement
sur la démobilisation des électeurs des
candidats éliminés au premier tour
quelques secondes quand même pour
regarder les autres candidats à cette
élection présidentielle
on les appelle et c'est pas péjoratif
mais les plus petits candidat c'est
nicolas dupont aignan qui est parmi les
plus grands chez les plus petits et or
on y reviendra dans un instant juste
peut-être un commentaire très court sur
ce panneau qu'on vend actuellement à
l'antenne parce que ce que l'on voit à
travers ces résultats c'est qu'il ya
quand même effectivement on a onze
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
mais on voit bien qu'au final ce qu'on
appelle les petits candidats entre
guillemets c'est à dire les candidats
faible capital électoral et bien se
partagent finalement très peu de voix et
que l'essentiel des intentions de vote
se concentre sur les principaux
candidats et on voit que c'est ce qui
montre aussi quand même que l'élection
présidentielle ça reste l'élection pour
élire un président de la république et
donc les candidatures de témoignage que
l'on a toujours dans un scrutin certes
elle recueille un certain nombre de
suffrages mais elles ne sont pas de
nature à faire la différence
à l'issue du premier tour pour parler de
dynamique à l'instant on va s'intéresser
à la dynamique d'un homme ossements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on va parler de jean luc mélenchon
qui est devenu la cible à présent de
tous les autres candidats street de
vilaines la suit
portée par les sondages jean luc
mélenchon est désormais la cible
privilégiée de ses adversaires à
commencer par benoît mme malgré un pacte
de non-agression entre les deux hommes
le candidat socialiste fait désormais
valoir ses différences
on ne peut pas faire des campagnes que
dans un rapport abstrait au peuple qui
passe par la relation césariste en
quelque sorte du tribun avec la foule
qui la regarde et qui finalement espère
lui inspire à ce que par son charisme il
entraîne le mouvement populaire vers les
hurlus le césarisme ou comment parler de
populisme sans le nommer
l'argument est également utilisé par
françois hollande dans les colonnes du
point le président de la république
déplore une mode mélenchon il s'en prend
ouvertement à son ancien adversaire de
il y à un péril face aux simplifications
face aux falsifications qui fait que
l'on regarde le spectacle du tribun
plutôt que le contenu de son texte
mais la droite n'est pas en reste pour
tenter de contrer à la vague mélenchon
la presse conservatrice ou libérale
s'attaque point par point à son
programme économique
ses adversaires quant à eux n'oublient
pas de rappeler qu'il a le soutien du
parti communiste pays économiquement
faibles ne sera jamais un pays
politiquement fort mes adversaires font
semblant de l'ignorer tel monsieur
mélenchon qui se rêve en capitaine du
cuirassé potemkine mais qui finira par
négocier la ferraille du titanic
vous pouvez trouver quelqu'un de
courageux au sympathique et après il
faut quand même lire les programmes et
j'invite tous les français moi le seul
chose que je dis inlassablement depuis
le début de cette campagne c'est comme
les contrats d'assurance faut lire les
notes en bas de page
une percée dans l'opinion qui n'est pas
forcément révélatrice dans les urnes en
2012 jean-luc mélenchon avait perdu 6
points entre les sondages et sur ce
score final de 11,1 pour tenter comment
est-ce que vous analysez cette remontée
de jean luc mélenchon c'est lui qui
porte la dynamique aujourd'hui qu'en
tant que candidat oui clairement la plus
forte dynamique observée au cours de
cette campagne électorale elle est pour
jean luc mélenchon envoyer tout à
l'heure il est crédité de 18 et demi
pour cent des intentions de vote parfois
un peu plus d'ailleurs chez certains de
nos confrères
et quand on regarde quelle est cette
progression justement par rapport au
début de la campagne 3ème homme il est
passé au fictivement statut de troisième
de troisième homme parfois mais surtout
il était crédité de seulement 10% des
intentions de vote il y encore deux mois
donc on voit que la progression est très
forte et cette progression s explique un
parent la très grande faiblesse de
benoît hamon la candidature du parti
socialiste qui n'a pas su finalement
fédérer son camp au sortir de la
primaire alors que l'électorat
socialiste en était ressorti très
fracturée et jean luc mélenchon et bien
il a profité de cette situation et il a
siphonné très clairement l'électorat
potentiel de benoît hamon
ce qui fait qu on en arrive quand même
au point aujourd'hui où jean luc
mélenchon récupère sur son nom davantage
d d'anciens électeurs de françois
hollande en 2012 que ne le fait
benoît hamon c'est dire combien la
situation de fragilité un comble regard
du quinquennat mais très forte pour but
normand et c'est un comble au regard du
quinquennat d'autant plus qu'on sait que
benoît hamon c'était quand même l'un des
principaux frondeurs au monde et des
rimes et alary mois il ya là une
question qui se pose est ce que cette
dynamique n'est pas à peu surévalué mais
quand on voit par exemple ce que
disaient les sondages en 2012 et ce qu'a
été le score de jean luc mélenchon lors
de l'angelus mélenchon des élections il
y avait quand même six points d'écart
entre le sondage et son score oui
effectivement et c'est d'ailleurs un
risque qui porte toujours au nez d'une
certaine façon de de jean luc mélenchon
lorsque l'on interroge le ses électeurs
potentiels sur le fait de savoir s'ils
sont sûrs de leur choix ou le 6 hésitent
encore et pourrait voter pour un autre
candidat
on voit que jean luc mélenchon il a
seulement 63% de ses électeurs
potentiels qui se disent certains de
leurs choix et donc 60 37 % qui disent
banon j'hésite en fait entre jean luc
mélenchon est un autre candidat et donc
c'est vrai que sous l'effet du vote
utile que l'on voit souvent à paraître
en fin de campagne électorale que
d'ailleurs il est très difficile de me
mesurée dans la dernière ligne droite
dans les sondages eh bien ça pourrait se
traduire par un report de personnes qui
finalement leur vote de coeur ce serait
plutôt jean luc mélenchon mais leur vote
de raison notamment pour faire barrage
soit françois fillon soit marine le pen
ce serait plutôt aujourd'hui emmanuel
maintenant je sais le vote utile l'enjeu
c'est sans doute le vote utile dans ses
nerfs se met ça qui fera la différence
le jour
c'est ça qui vous fera probablement la
différence ou en tout cas qui fera
davantage la différence que lors des
deux précédentes élections
présidentielles parce que compte tenu
des écarts très faibles entre les quatre
premiers candidats et bien le choix des
indécis sera plus déterminant cette
année qu'il ne l'était par le passé par
yves marie cann on va poursuivre cette
émission en parlant de la droite avec
une campagne difficile mais jusqu'au
bout pour françois fillon le candidat de
la droite enchaîne les meetings est
l'occasion pour lui de renvoyer marine
le pen et jean luc mélenchon doses à dos
et de dénoncer une france malade de sa
bureaucratie céline martèlent les ânes
plantier dernière ligne droite décisive
pour françois fillon hier soir à
chassieu 7000 personnes sont venues
l'écouter selon les organisateurs la
veille ils étaient 3000 à marseille les
meetings s'enchaînent et font le plein
de quoi rassurer le candidat de la
droite sur ses chances de victoire
merci de votre enthousiasme qui va nous
permettre de bousculer tous les
obstacles qui ont été placés sur notre
route toujours derrière marine le pen et
emmanuel macron dans les sondages
françois fillon le libéral se fait plus
rassembleur il se présente comme le
défenseur des classes moyennes les
classes moyennes ont été les premières
victimes du laxisme budgétaire et de
l'absence de réformes depuis 30 ans
elles n'ont pas vu les bénéfices de
cette mondialisation on leur vente est
et qui c'est vrai a d'abord profité aux
plus aisés comme françois fillon ses
soutiens affirme que l'élection se joue
maintenant dont les derniers jours de
campagne
aujourd'hui on est dans le sprint final
et dans ceux ci street fair a lancé tous
les atouts et tous les talents de
françois fillon
on le voit chaque meeting de plus en
plus de monde on le voit sur le terrain
une mobilisation forte des électrices et
électeurs de la droite et du centre
aussi le collage des affiches et un
tracteur
le terrain un programme de huit pages
qui est envoyé qui est distribué à 14
millions d'exemplaires donc on va faire
la différence à la fin sur le programme
une confiance affichée qui tranche avec
l'inquiétude des militants sur l'avenir
du parti en cas de défaite
tout le monde a été aujourd'hui
solidaires du moins en façade de
monsieur fillon mais j'ai peur qu
effectivement les langues se délient
après coeur et que ce soit effectivement
d'un règlement de compte on est loin des
caméras
les sarkozystes ont déjà prévu plusieurs
réunions pour étudier tous les scénarios
de l'après présidentielle et nous
accueillons sur ce plateau stéphanie des
pierres bonjour stéphanie bonjour vous
suivez la campagne de françois fillon
sur le terrain on va essayer de prendre
le pouls des militants quelle est
l'ambiance cette femme campagne dans le
confirme alors l'ambiance est dans le
camp fillon sait on y va on y croit
encore mais parfois c'est plus de la
commande en de l'auto persuasion que de
la vraie conviction les militants eux
ils croient ceux qui sont dans les
meetings c'est le noyau dur ce qu'on
appelle le noyau dur
combatifs les gens sont la vdi croire
mais les ne font plus part de leurs
doutes les militants ce qui était le cas
il ya trois semaines un mois et on sent
que le discours de françois fillon et
ses équipes marche sur ses militants là
c'est à dire de dire le sol qui
proposent l'alternance c'est moi si vous
voulez l'alternance est pour moi qu'il
faut voter vous votez pour un programme
et pas pour une personne donc faire fi
de toutes les critiques de toutes les
affaires et ça semble marcher sur ce
noyau dur les proches de françois fillon
espère que ça va marcher dans l'isoloir
c'est c'est ce qu'ils appellent un peu
un vote de raison j'espère que ça
marchera au premier sa marche sur le
noyau dur c'est ce que nous dit
stéphanie fait mais aussi ce que vous
analysez dans vos études oui c'est ce
que l'on voit des gens on a vu quand
même là la permanence d'un noyau dur en
faveur de françois fillon il n'est
jamais descendu en dessous de 10 7 %
dans les intentions de vote au cours de
cette campagne
et si on regarde comment est-ce que les
choses ont évolué au cours de ces deux à
trois dernières semaines
il a même regagné du terrain puisqu'il
est généralement aujourd'hui à 19 ou 20
%
donc il a réussi à élargir légèrement
son socle maintenant il ya encore la
question de savoir ce qu'il peut les rg
encore un peu plus justement pour se
qualifier au second tour
il ya une question d'ambiance aussi on
le voit dans les mythes
c'est un peu électrique c'est aussi ce
que vous avez ressenti oui c'est
électrique et notamment vis-à-vis des
journalistes on le voit les gens sont
très méfiants certains refusent de nous
répondre m violence la violence parfois
violents alors bas de la violence
physique nous on a eu ce problème là
contrairement à d'autres qu'on leur doit
mais violence verbale des insultes des
doigts d'honneur une grosse tension par
exemple avec ma collègue tout début mars
à nîmes ma collègue voulait aller faire
défaire des images d'un côté du meeting
ont leur empêchait de passer elle s'est
retrouvée encerclée
alors c'est une certaine pression pas de
menaces physiques mais une pression
c'est compliqué de circuler dans les
meetings c'est compliqué de parler de
parler aux militants
et vous avez vu aussi le candidat fillon
quelque chose a changé chez lui alors
oui quelque chose a changé c'est lui au
sens où depuis trois semaines un mois
dans ses meetings par exemple quand ils
arrivent au métier ils rentrent par une
allée d'honneur par ces jeunes militants
sign il l'a fait très tard dans la
campagne alors il ne le fait plus depuis
strasbourg la semaine dernière où il a
été en farine et désormais ils
recommencent à rentrer discrètement etc
en revanche ce qu'il fait c'est qu'il se
il arrive en meeting il se met debout
sur une chaise elle se fait applaudir et
ça c'est quelque chose que françois
fillon ne faisait pas du tout il y a
deux mois trois mois il cherche à
galvaniser ses troupes
moi j'étais à strasbourg la semaine
dernière juste après la farine âge à la
fin du meeting
il est sur la marche de sa voiture et
lève les bras en l'air ça c'est un
comportement qui ne ressemblait pas à
françois fillon il ya encore quelques
semaines quelque chose at il changé dans
la personnalité de françois fillon
toujours sur les études en tout cas dans
la personnalité de françois fillon telle
qu'elle est perçue aujourd'hui par les
français on voit que de manière générale
son image elle s'est pas améliorée au
cours des dernières semaines cyr qui a
eu un vrai décrochage sous l'effet des
affaires et il n'a pas regagné le
terrain perdu et finalement le vote de
droite qui se reportent aujourd'hui sur
sa candidature effectuant c'est pas un
vote de coeur c'est comme vous le disiez
un vote de raison parce que m'a
effectivement pas m'aimer mais me
soutenir et c'est ça c'est françois
fillon résume lui même la situation par
cette phrase qu'il a prononcée le
week-end le week-end dernier et je pense
que c'est véritablement ce que l'on voit
aussi à travers nos enquêtes
merci beaucoup stéphanie on va
maintenant à présent parler d'un autre
candidat et vous en parliez tout à
l'heure avec marie cann qui baisse c'est
le candidat
benoît hamon pourtant reid jette ses
dernières forces dans la bataille et les
à mon magasin
mario châteaulin le terrain voilà
l'option choisie par benoît hamon pour
ses 11 derniers jours de campagne à
villeurbanne près de lyon le candidat à
l'élection présidentielle visite d'un
centre social accompagné de la ministre
de l'éducation
au programme projection d'un
documentaire sur les habitants du
quartier entre sentiment d'abandon et
volonté d'aller de l'avant
on pourrait presque y voir un parallèle
avec la campagne du candidat mais moi je
suis pas abandonnée par les gens je suis
abandonnée parler parce qu'ils
abandonnent toujours mais on ne croyait
pas moi j'ai c'est ici que je trouve moi
je prends beaucoup de forces dans les
les quartiers
parce qu'ici on sait la preuve très du
quotidien donc ça me donne le là aussi
de l'énergie
voilà mais oui et jolie métaphore pas
bêtes pas bêtes pas la peine de lui
rappeler les mauvais sondages benoît
hamon n'est pas dupe mais il veut
s'afficher comme celui qui est à
l'écouté des français
jusqu'au dernier moment et jusque devant
chez eux dans les tâches aux demandes
des associations qui aurait vu en bourse
et dans son équipe on doit bien
regretter que les enfants n'est pas le
droit de vote
plus sérieusement on tente de balayer
les rumeurs sur la démotivation des
troupes
je crois au travail de terrain je crois
on n'a pas de plan b toute façon donc on
va aller jusqu'au bout on va travailler
jusqu'au bout
de plus en plus et puis après les urnes
des livreront leur verdict mais c'est un
petit peu difficile
c'est une campagne difficile une
campagne présidentielle c'est pas
c'est pas des vacances le club m c'est
sûr que c'est difficile faire campagne
puisque c'est la seule solution
l'autocritique et les reproches ce sera
pour le lendemain du premier tour
el zhar obama nous a rejoints vous avez
suivi le candidat benoît hamon nous en
ligue 12
le candidat comme de militants il voit
les sondages il les voit tous les jours
la presse le lui rappellent constamment
à chaque fois qu'il vient visiter un
endroit et qu'il aimerait parler du fond
on lui parle de son décrochage dans les
sondages donc ils le voient bien après
le blues
je pense que si vous voulez ils sont
déjà en train de de devoir aussi la
stratégie d'après ils savent très bien
qu elles reprochent ils vont faire
notamment au parti socialiste et sur
l'absence de soutien d'un très grand
nombre de figures du parti socialiste
viendra aussi le temps de l'autocritique
sur la campagne a aussi des erreurs
qu'ont pu être commises et le blues les
militants y croit encore mais c'est vrai
que depuis le début il regrette quand
même qu'ils aient pas eu d'alliance avec
jean luc mélenchon et ils se divisent
entre deux parties ce qu'ils voulaient
une alliance derrière jean-luc mélenchon
quitte à voter même pour jean luc
mélenchon et devenons annonce d east et
ce qu'ils voulaient a impérativement que
non un monde maintienne à coûte que
coûte sa candidature américaine qu'est
ce que vous percevez vous étude sur sur
ce ce cas de benoît hamon qui est
fictive d'un double siphonnage il suffit
d un double siphonnage effectivement
puisqu'il est pris sur sa gauche par
jean luc mélenchon sur sa droite par
emmanuel macron est aujourd'hui ben
benoît hamon il expérimente finalement
la fronde à à fronts renversés c'est à
dire que il est allé quand même l'année
dernière jusqu'à pousser une motion de
censure contre un gouvernement de gauche
et il le paye aussi aujourd'hui dans les
enquêtes d'intentions de vote puisque on
voit bien que les premiers finalement à
fuir la candidature de benoît hamon
eh bien ce sont les sympathiques une
partie significative des sympathisants
socialistes
on a plus de sympathisants socialistes
aujourd'hui qu'ils se reportent sur la
candidature d'emmanuel macron que sur
celle de benoît hamon
c'est dire quand même combien
aujourd'hui benoît mans et finalement il
n'a pas réussi a finalement à ressouder
sa famille politique
à
à soigner les plaies qui était béante
d'ailleurs au sortir de la primaire
parce qu'il faut le rappeler si benoît
hamon a gagné la primaire du parti
socialiste en janvier c'est pas
forcément avec l'électorat du parti
socialiste c'est plutôt avec celui de la
gauche du parti socialiste
et on a vu cette semaine à une interview
du président de la république qui a pas
forcément aidé benoît hamon ça j'imagine
que l'on doit beaucoup en parler o sinon
oui après on veut croire que de toute
façon le président de la république
avait fait son choix il ya bien
longtemps et que c'est pas grave il
était membre du parti socialiste- comme
un public voilà mais que c'était pas
vraiment une surprise on dit non mais
c'est une clarification il n'y a pas de
problème de toute façon on est on veut
pas forcément de soutien ni du président
de la république comme on voulait pas
forcément du soutien de manuel valls
mais c'est vrai qu'on n'hésite pas à
parler du mot de sabotage en tout cas
dans l'équipe de benoît hamon sur la
campagne du candidat est juste pour
rebondir il ya aussi eu c'est vrai
c'était un début de campagne après
l'élection de benoît hamon pas la
primaire socialiste qui a été consacrée
uniquement à des querelles d'appareil
avec europe ecologie les verts est un
feuilleton pendant trois semaines ça
clairement ça a été une erreur
stratégique très très grave avec a coûté
certainement à benoît hamon un début de
campagne qui avait vraiment du mal à
avancer quoi eh bien merci beaucoup l
amont à gaza pour cet éclairage est
l'une des images de la semaine
maintenant c'est cette accolade entre
françois bayrou et emmanuel macron s'est
passé à pau où le candidat de en marche
était en meeting voilà l'accolade de la
semaine et je vous propose d'écouter
tout de suite ce qu'a dit le candidat
dans marche
notre projet c'est un projet de liberté
par le travail et dans le travail c'est
ainsi que la vraie liberté que
l'opportunité se reconstruit c'est pour
cela que nous simplifieront le droit du
travail pour le ramener au plus près du
terrain pour redonner aux accords
majoritaires d'entreprises et de
branches toute leur place pour être à la
hauteur du moment que nous vivons ne
promettons pas le grand soir ne
promettons pas de déchirer des
constitutions d'en faire de nouvelles
faisons fonctionner celle là
alors juste une question sur emmanuel
macron est ce que vous nous parler de
marge d'erreur tout à l'heure pour les
quatre candidats mais ce que pour lui on
peut considérer l'électorat comme plutôt
cimenté ou plutôt volatile alors ils
restent volatiles en partie parce qu'il
ya toujours des indécis parmi les
électeurs des manuels macron de l'ordre
de 3 sur 10 mais ce qui le plus frappant
quand même par rapport à il ya un mois
c'est que l'électorat potentiel des
manuels macron c'est quand même
considérablement solidifier c'est à dire
qu'il ya un mois on avait environ entre
cas aux alentours de 45 % de ces
électeurs potentiels qui se disait sûrs
de leur choix
aujourd'hui on est plutôt entre 65% et
70% de ses électeurs donc on voit quand
même que les choses se sont améliorées
de ce point de vue là et c'est plutôt
effectivement une bonne nouvelle pour le
candidat dans un contexte de
resserrement des courbes est ce que vous
estimez aujourd'hui qu'on est dans la
phase de cristallisation comme on
l'appelle ça si vous revenez sourire on
est dans la phase de l'acte de
cristallisation il faut toujours garder
à l'esprit que c'est un processus en
fait qui se fait tout au long de la
campagne il peut y avoir une
accélération et on est effectivement à
priori dans cette phase d'accélération
ceci étant dit il restera toujours des
indécis jusqu'au dernier moment et la
question c'est à voir ma comment est ce
que vont voter ces indécis
lorsqu'ils seront au pied du mur c'est à
dire lorsqu'il s'agira de mettre un
bulletin dans l'enveloppé
car on va parler tout de suite des
petits candidats qui essaye aussi de
faire entendre leur voix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors et vous avez aussi on a vu tout à
l'heure un sondage sur ces petits le
plus grand des petits dans votre tableau
c'est nico nicolas dupont aignan qui
arrive en tête dans cette deuxième
partie de tableau
eh bien il a défendu cette semaine lui
aussi sa vision de la france écoutez il
faut absolument que l'on passe d'un
aujourd'hui 58% de français
propriétaires à 75%
c'est l'objectif je veux qu'on mette fin
à cette injustice dans noël celle de
voir des français qui sont restées toute
leur vie en hlm et qui à la fin si on
calculait ce qu'ils ont payé de loyer de
charge aurait pu s'acheter deux
appartements
cela veut dire que je veux inventer le
crédit bail comme pour les voitures
crédit bail sur 30 ans 40 ans et à la
fin de ce paiement de ses loyers
on devient propriétaire de son logement
social difficile de se faire entendre
pour ces petits candidats on faisait
tout à la mène sur des thèmes un peu
grand public est ce que par exemple
nicolas dupont aignan peut créer la
surprise au delà des 3 % d'intentions de
vote que vous lui prêtez dans votre vie
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les crédits de
3% des intentions vote c'est-à-dire un
score comparable à celui qu'il avait
obtenu au premier tour de la
présidentielle en 2012
on voit que c'est difficile pour pour
les petits candidats en général et pour
nicolas dupont aignan en particulier
d'émerger finalement dans un paysage
politique qui quand même dominé par ceux
qui font figure de favoris alors on
avait vu les courbes frais la courbe
frémir pour nicolas dupont aignan il y à
une quinzaine de jours lorsqu'il a fait
son coup d'éclat sur le plateau du 20h
de tf1 on a vu à ce moment là c'est ses
intentions de vote progressé il est
monté jusqu'à 5% me vois bien que bas au
delà de ce coup d'éclat et bien les
choses se sont normalisées il est
retourné sur les 3 % est-ce qu'il peut
bénéficier des déçus de françois fillon
par exemple oui en tout cas il aurait pu
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas dans ce
que l'on mesure maintenant effectivement
dans les dix derniers jours de campagne
il peut encore réussir finalement à se
faire entendre on est dans la perte
d'égalité des temps de parole entre les
candidats mais à la main qu'il a la
marge à la marge mais ça veut dire qu'il
a autant aussi de visibilité qu'un
françois fillon donc ça peut lui
permettre aussi de faire la différence
non pas bien entendu d'atteindre les 10%
mais au moins là bas
symbolique des 5% on va parler
maintenant de l'autre côté de l'extrême
gauche si vous voulez bien on va parler
de nathalie arthaud qui évidemment et
c'est aussi d'exister et qui s'en prend
à jean luc mélenchon
ecoutez jean luc mélenchon tient sur
l'immigration des propos plus qu'ambiguë
d'un côté pour ne pas heurter une partie
de ses électeurs
il promet de ce site donner les papiers
à ceux qui ont un contrat de travail
mais juste après il n'hésite pas à
affirmer qu'il n'ya pas moyen d'occuper
tout le monde et justifie donc
l'expulsion de je cite ceux qui n'ont ni
papier ni contrat de travail car dit il
c'est la loi et je ne sais pas quoi en
faire
alors il ya deux candidats d'extrême
gauche nathalie arthaud il ya philippe
poutou également qu'ils sont compris
entre combien les 0,5 et 2 % tout à fait
est ce qu'ils sont en train de se manger
entre eux finalement oui c'est le sait
le risque effectivement et ça on l'avait
déjà vu d'ailleurs en 2012 c'est à dire
que jean luc mélenchon il avait siphonné
aussi l'espace de l'extrême gauche ce
qui avait plus qu'à imaginer encore fait
et c'est encore le cas cette fois
puisque effectivement sa dynamique
qu'elle empêche toute dynamique du côté
de l'extrême gauche
alors après si on regarde entre philippe
poutou et nathalie arthaud on voit que
c'est philippe poutou qui est plutôt en
train de prendre quand même l'ascendant
sur nathalie arthaud et ça va le
candidat de lecocq le candidat philippe
poutou il le doit beaucoup
finalement à son à sa performance lors
du débat du 4 avril diffusés par les
chaînes d'information où il a notamment
pris à parti marine le pen et c'est vrai
que ça finalement ça lui a permis de
permis de passer de 0 5 point
d'intentions de vote à 2 à 2 et demi
pour cent d'intentions de vote
aujourd'hui voilà marc goua nathalie
arthaud ça ne bouge pas faire front pour
nathalie arthaud ça ne bouge pas et je
pense qu'effectivement les deux
candidats d'extrême gauche aujourd'hui
il se neutralisent l'un et l'autre et
c'est vrai qu'une candidature commune
aurait sans doute plus de poids plus de
force dans le souligner alors pour
résumer d'un mot c'est donc
l'incertitude qui domine donc avec un
carré d'as au début mais qui se tiennent
dans un mouchoir de poche
et quelle autre
conclusion vous en tirez à huit jours de
du premier tour la conclusion principale
c'est qu'effectivement il ya une
incertitude très forte du fait du
resserrement des courbes du fait du
resserrement du rapport de force et que
contrairement aux deux précédents
scrutins présidentiels cette fois ci ce
sont peut-être les indécis qui auront le
dernier mot
parce qu'effectivement les comptes ou de
les configurer beaucoup de configuration
de second tour aujourd'hui son sont
possibles et donc de leur choix à la
faim dépendra sans doute le nom des deux
qualifiés pour le second tour que l'on
connaîtra aussi tard y compris pour le
premier tour les résultats seront connus
plus tard ils seront ils pour ils
risquent d'être connu un peu plus qu'un
peu plus tard puisque les bureaux de
vote fermeront plus tard que d'habitude
c'était 18 heures dans les premiers
bureaux de vote jusqu'à présent ce sera
dix neuf heures désormais et ça va pas
vous faciliter la tâche et nous non plus
merci beaucoup yves marie cann on
analysera évidemment la semaine
prochaine la dernière semaine de
campagne très bonne semaine à tous
attrait m
[Musique]